bonjour je m'appelle dans la Nintendo
Saint-Joseph et en fait je suis chef
d'entreprise dans l'entreprise Barbie
Barbie ça rit c'est une entreprise basée
dans l'import de vêtements venu de
l'Inde donc des sacs traditionnels des
pentes habitées
d'habits a réétend encore d'évolution
c'est-à-dire qu'on compte créer
peut-être un magasin mais surtout comme
nous on marche avec le commerce ambulant
donc on veut vraiment s'exprime par tout
soit dit de la Réunion et monter de
nouveaux projets par exemple avec des
organisations de mariage et tout
actuellement dans l'entreprise on n'a
pas de salariés on a que des commerciaux
indépendants c'est-à-dire ceux qui
travaillent pour nous commissionnement
pour l'année 2015 on recherche des
commerciaux ça sera d'abord
indépendant mais qui se comment dire il
y aura des postes en CDI nous on a
commencé comme ça en tant qu'indépendant
on faisait du porte-à-porte et des
personnes on a fait notre page Facebook
et donc je pense que toute personne a sa
chance déjà pour débuter en tant que
indépendant pour être commercial
indépendant il faut quand même avoir le
soupir il faut être à l'écoute des
personnes surtout savoir conseiller si
vous êtes neuf nous commerciaux
indépendants vous pouvez faire ça de
plusieurs manières il faut il faut
vraiment avoir le permis si vous faites
du porte-à-porte mais si comme nous vous
ouvrez une page professionnelle
baby-sari pour présenter vos produits
c'est aussi très bien
un commercial doit avoir une bonne
connaissance du produit
être capable de valoriser l'image de la
marque prendre en compte les attentes de
sa clientèle savoir fidéliser et
prospecter de nouveaux clients
on recherche plusieurs couturiers tu as
aussi c'est possible surtout dit pour
pouvoir
emmener nos clientes VL quoi qu'il voire
qu'elle puisse tailler cette jolie sur
mesure et même fait assez les autres
vêtements comme on a dit
je mesure et selon les goûts de la pièce
aujourd'hui nous on aimerait vraiment
des couturières qui connaissent le tauli
qui savent le faire bien sur mesure pour
que quand la personne le porte ça pose
bien et c'est parfait quoi on demande
que du savoir-faire du coup on se
déplacera vers les personnes ou quand
ces personnes là ils viendront chez nous
on verra la qualité de leur travail des
chapeaux commencés et sinon nous on
recherche pas de diplôme ou quoi que ce
soit parce que quand vous avez dit au
début nous on veut que des personnes
très motivées et passionnées par ce
qu'ils font famille ça arrive c'est une
jeune entreprise
on est tous des personnes dynamiques et
motivées et les personnes qui
travailleront avec nous on aimerait
autant qu'ils sont aussi souriants
dynamiques et motivés
une couturière doit savoir être à
l'écoute faire preuve de patience et de
concentration être doté d'un sens du
toucher et d'un sens artistique avoir le
goût de la perfection
S
bonjour agario 42 ans je suis
administratif et je recherche dans le
secteur du secrétariat j'ai obtenu mon
Bac Professionnel information conseil
orientation j'ai poursuivi en BTS
Négociation client tout cela dans le
cadre de la validation des acquis en
2006 j'habite à Saint-Denis je souhaite
donc
dans l'idéal Saint-Denis aux alentours
ou jusqu'à Saint-Paul j'ai eu plusieurs
compétences donc de 2007 jusqu'à 2014 en
tant que secrétaire donc secrétariat
polyvalent j'ai eu l'opportunité d'avoir
une formation approfondie dans tout ce
qui est logiciel Word Excel intranet
internet
même en parallèle avoir une formation
dans les logiciels financiers tels que
j'ai ce projet astres je suis une
personne donc disponible sérieuse
discrète mais surtout loyal
j'adore tout ce qui est relations
humaines j'adore faire des randonnées du
footing assez souvent et du yoga je suis
une personne dynamique
aimant la bonne humeur si mon profil
vous intéresse n'hésitez pas à m'appeler
contactez-nous sur notre page Facebook
www.facebook.com/974tv ou par téléphone
0262 92 37 60
de 7 4 CV votre émission au service de
l'emploi à la Réunion